[Music]  time running out for the government's  transportation mask mandate that is  unless it's extended the rule expires  monday but regulators haven't figured  out what to do just yet some travelers  say it's time for the government to step  back and let them decide whether or not  to cover their face but most americans  according to a recent poll are in favor  of keeping it in place and extending it  once again here's what some members of  the airline industry say  we need to remove these mandates we have  an unpredictable virus with many  variants but we're seeing again and  again these variants are less severe  roger dow president of the u.s travel  association he and three others wrote a  letter to the white house pushing to end  the mandate but again nothing will  happen until the cdc makes a move